[Music]
so we are entering a time uh
i think everyone's calling it the jk
news renaissance the renaissance the
renaissance i like it do people agree
with that statement what's the jk news
renaissance
renaissance yeah
you know what's funny is um this new era
since we all have other side gigs
and that this is no longer our main main
we can do all kinds of funny experiments
we don't care anymore baby
am i wrong am i wrong it's like we could
go to vegas
and play we just [ __ ] double down on
people's rumors saying that you were
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] us
off you're god look at this
you're like oh i made another group no
[ __ ] you guys i don't need you anymore
right so we played with that but that's
the best part i actually like you guys
that's a healthy relationship it's
awesome that's what's funny right so we
played into it people actually believed
it and then we did the whole [ __ ]
skit out there we got the trump tower we
could have got any other place yeah but
we had to get the trump tower also could
have eaten any other buffet
and i wish we did for the buffet that
was a must
okay that was a buffet where i was like
i paid for this for nine days
nine long days yeah i was [ __ ] up that
was probably one of the worst buffets i
think let me let me tell you let me tell
you something that's dedication
though man out of all of this really
good buffets that one was
and it wasn't just because it was like
the food quality it just felt kind of
sad
yeah my life vitality dropped yeah but
there was a consistent plastic you taste
in everything yeah yeah when you walk in
in the middle so you're saying it's
consistent
carver looks at you like what the [ __ ]
he's trying to help you out dude he's
like my family's in prison back there
please don't eat here it's it's bad for
us
but you know what makes it worth it is
because i knew that the appreciation of
me
showing you the food of your culture
right circus
but there's comments they're saying that
was a [ __ ] hilarious scene
and i was like it was so worth it and we
were out of budget because we spent 20
grand at the trump tower so we had to go
there and it just kind of worked out
that way it was hilarious for us for
sure and it was my idea to go to the
trump tower obviously because you know
joe calls me and he's like okay so we
we're just at jk today and obviously you
weren't here because you're moving he's
like here's my pitch he's like we're
gonna do this thing at the trump tower
and it's your idea and i'm like all
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay guys this is mine this is me
was awesome
no we did a whole [ __ ] off the record
about being in the trump tower yeah we
did a whole [ __ ] joke i wasn't here
for it but yeah it was good i forgot who
was here for it trump was but you did
fill me in after to your credit that's
what i'm saying and then you're like
it's your idea we're gonna do this take
100 responsibilities and the best part
is like when we're we're about to do the
video
joe's like okay that first take that's
not what we want and he's like here's
this here's the take that we want and
then joe's like well because steve's a
huge trump supporter
we gotta play into it dude it's so funny
you know what i will say whatever the
rumor is we gotta double down if he sees
white he must be a trump guy let's go
oh and a jabberwocky supporter yeah i
like the job well yeah
what i will say
about this renaissance
is that in retrospect when looking at
that triple yes that kind of felt like
um
in this new season kind of like our
retreat
yeah for sure yeah right
it was good
we all did become closer as a result of
that yeah yeah and because some of the
ideas that like you know
uh
maybe some of us might not naturally be
inclined to like pitch
most of it
um
having to commit to it felt like having
to commit to this brotherhood oh yeah
for sure you know what i mean
so it was really really cool but there's
just a sausage fish in here though yeah
don't we need more feminine energy and
different perspectives but that's why
i'm here i thought that's why anthony's
here too i'm the feminine energy of the
group i don't know what you mean by that
but but doesn't it
but what about the eye candy that's what
we need right because that's what people
miss they miss the eye candy anthony and
ryan is there
or just ryan
ryan did you just flash your breasts i
gave them eye candy dude i know they've
been
we got some horny incels and [ __ ] that's
been missing the and then steve's the
big dick of the group you know
sometimes sometimes uh because um i'm
part of this dance club called kendra's
uh sometimes fans will ask this question
like how come there's no girls even
though we have girls now but in the past
in kenja's yeah how come there's no
girls and stuff like that you guys put
girls did you say [ __ ] you [ __ ]
they could never be storm chasers that's
what you said our fan our fans were like
hey [ __ ] ken just
my point
my point is that you know there's also a
bunch of like girl clubs out there that
don't have guys in it and like those
safe spaces that allow for whatever
chemistry or conversation come about is
natural just you know what i mean and in
this space even though for sure there
have been like women in the past that
have been part of the show and whatnot
but
in this renaissance in the season
because it's like all dudes i gotta
admit the chemistry and the fun that i
have here is on a whole other level and
i want to take credit for being this
genius who's like
[Laughter]
i had this trajectory right yeah like
it's been so
female empowerment focused
that it was that that everyone this this
space for men
disappeared yeah so then so then i'm
like we need to bring that back because
then maybe
we could we could at least represent the
guys that don't want to be in cells
right but see that's my that's my
narrative to kind of squeeze in here but
the reality is the girls just don't want
to [ __ ] come here
that's the truth so the truth is they
started dropping like flies and after a
while
it was kind of hard to you know have
regulars come here but i said you know
what it's a new era
and i do i do really believe like this
is just me honestly speaking we are
living in this weird era of redefining
what is masculinity what is a man a good
person supposed to be right and i feel
like there's just so much of these
confusing role models right especially
like the whole men's right stuff and i
don't really get it but it sounds like
anti-woman wait guys don't need rights
what's men's rights what is that um
it's guys who are i love that we should
just leave it at that what is that first
of all guys who are playing world of
warcraft need something to listen to and
we try to be that we try to be that
every [ __ ] time okay
and that and that's it that's that's
what i meant
but then what i've been witnessing
though is that like there's a lot of
there's a lot of separation right
there's like there's this weird [ __ ]
thing going on with like super democrats
super republicans super [ __ ] pro
female i hate men super [ __ ] male
male guys that are like no women allowed
i'm running away from all women male
guys you know i'm not the [ __ ] male
now right not to be confused with male
men because that's a different
profession you want to know when
ashley's the best
everyone acts like it's like
joe and bart or whoever they were like
no more chicks on jk and not
what actually happened which is like
there's a lot of people who are really
mean to the chicks here
exactly and the chicks are like we don't
want to go on here anymore because
everyone's so mean and then no no no
it's not the only thing you make it
sound like it's the word
the comments are amazing yeah yeah yeah
the comments are mean
that's what it sounds like
yeah you look at that
i was like wait no the comments are so
mean to these chicks and then they're
just like i don't want to go anymore
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this is not worth it at
all i won't go here anymore and then the
comments are like see you guys want to
hear the chicks here
what a sausage fish it's like yeah you
made it a soccer mess you stupid
[ __ ] yeah you like the titties
they're gone because of you you no more
no more [ __ ] anything you know what's
crazy you know what's crazy no more eye
candy here i don't know why chicks get
it so bad because like sometimes i'll
say crazy [ __ ] right when i say crazy
[ __ ]
like deals like on her instagram
whatever and then
dms damns dance i can't believe we're
[ __ ] with this guy i don't even i
can't believe i'm a kid with this guy
and boom boom it's just all this [ __ ]
hate right she goes oh my god what did
you say on jk news i'm like oh i don't
know she goes check your dms check your
tv i'm like i look and i'm like oh we
love you on jk it's so [ __ ] good i'm
like oh i don't have anything because
they're two [ __ ] cowards hey babe i'm
doing good because it's too [ __ ]
coward to talk to him directly or any of
us they go to the women and she hasn't
even been on in [ __ ] like three years
or some [ __ ] what happened to the chicks
here like what the [ __ ] like it's like
yeah no [ __ ] that's the thing is like
and a lot of and then that's why that's
also why a lot of girls just like they
stick on big mood because the big mood
fans don't [ __ ] with them the way that
[ __ ] jk fans [ __ ] with i wonder how
it lasted so long
it's because they're being nice oh my
god everyone's so [ __ ] stupid though
they're like i don't know i don't get i
yelled at this chick for like four hours
why won't she respond to me
and not not everybody who's watching
right now obviously the ones that tend
to unsubscribe and they came back later
but you know who you are though
commenters are different than the normal
audience let's be honest yeah yeah
that's a hundred percent true a
different thing because there's also
[ __ ] out there that make multiple
accounts and just keep talking [ __ ]
religiously and try to you know yeah but
they also say the real fans me and joe
[ __ ] up when we bought luna at five
dollars
[Laughter]
today's video is brought to you by
curology
okay check this out curology they come
in a little box like this super chill
every month to my door they got really
cool
stuff because
i don't like doing skincare
and um
i never did it until
i started working with curology like
over three years ago they've been
sending this to me every single month
and they made it super easy and simple
for me boom we got the cleanser i just
do this in the shower real quick real
easy
moisturizer
you know going to places like las vegas
my desert face turns into the sahara
desert so so dry right okay but best of
all is this here it says my name joseph
fujitsukawa right and i have a special
formula just for me that you guys can
customize for your particular goals that
you need for your skincare routine
helps you get the [ __ ] yeah and i got a
lot of that from one woman oh
guys if you want ultra easy skincare
that's actually made for your skin
curology is the way to go you'll get a
custom prescription cream made for you
by a dermatology provider for your
specific goals whether that's tackling
acne clogged pores skin texture dark
spots fine lines or something else you
start by taking a short online skin quiz
and if it's a good fit they'll ship you
your formula right to your door
smells good too it feels good i think
that it makes skin care really easy for
me and as a dude we don't always have
the best reputations for hygiene nah and
i think it's because it comes with
laziness and let's make it extremely
simple to beautify yourself and try to
take care of yourself because hey if
it's going to be easy why not do it but
they also have cool little things like
this
which is chapstick i use it every day
it's like a lightsaber too let me show
you guys it's pretty cool you you pull
down and it comes out like that and i go
ah ah
kiss me baby it's pretty awesome cause
then now you can eat the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
get started with curology just like we
did with a free 30-day trial at
curology.com
off the record just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash off the record to start
your free 30-day trial cancel at a time
prescription is subject to consultation
i mean did you get wrecked or what dude
you put five grand didn't change your
life forever but instead you talked [ __ ]
and you got wrecked dude you got so
wrecked i love it when we got [ __ ]
petty whop on the podcast
they had this information you wreck
yourself so hard or what they've been
watching every [ __ ] video every
single video what i know what stephen
joe invested in yeah but you didn't buy
it yet stupid [ __ ] they could
have put a couple hundred bucks in they
would have thousands you could weigh
that half for over a year thank you well
this one's new but thank you
because i could afford it you know i
mean how many millionaires did you make
wow over ten easy a dozen
not many people warren buffett
and [ __ ] him though [ __ ] him he did the
old way i don't like it that way
and me being the you know me you know we
all love to troll and [ __ ] you know but
i do have to give it up to you steve you
know that's another million you made for
me too
you know it's a big yeah a pleasure
honestly you were one of the few people
who were like this is a five-year plan
for me i'm gonna do this and you said it
with at the jump you're like i'm gonna
i'm gonna get in it's a five-year move
for me and you became a millionaire
twice
um
you can only become it twice if you lose
the first million though that's but
that's the beauty right that is the
beauty that doesn't happen in five years
the beauty is in the struggle yeah when
does anybody turn like a couple thousand
dollars into like a million dollars
twice but in reality you don't realize
it until you cash out that's why it's
called realized gains and losses if you
don't understand how the game works it
goes up and down in value all day but
you got to minimize risk you have to
attack the game in a different way like
like the way that we're attacking the
game like we could print bitcoin print
it right because we didn't buy bitcoin
and hold bitcoin this whole time we were
um
migrating our funds into other assets
like luna and so because of that we
actually beat bitcoin in the ass and the
ratios so we can accumulate more assets
um because of that
with less pain points so so that becomes
much easier i can now cash out and that
was my whole plan the whole time i told
my crypto corner crew i'm like hey look
we can um
you can you can just buy bitcoin now and
chill if you want to that's a strategy
in it of itself but if you want to win
in the ratios against bitcoin that's how
you print bitcoin that's how you mine
bitcoin better than just buying an ant
miner or something like that you can
actually buy a crypto that will beat
bitcoin the ratios and i've done this
like three times now it's not like i'm
[ __ ] new to this it's i've done this
every run but you're a con artist steve
i know i'm a congress it sucks it's kind
of my dude my corners my corners are so
sad and who were these millionaires that
you made they're just imaginary so it's
all [ __ ] i'm just making it up it's
a fever dream you don't be genius let's
interview all the ones that made it bro
that'll be [ __ ] that'll be a dope
video yeah yeah yeah let's do it it's
actually those are all crisis actors
they're [ __ ] fake like the sandy hook
ones right yeah hey that's why we're in
jk and that's my favorite thing to point
out to people is like yeah every time i
want jk like everyone knows i talk about
crypto and then everyone in the room is
like man we all got wrecked because of
steve oh no they're not doing that
because we like watch rolls why aren't
they doing that i got wrecked because of
steve
yeah how rick
half a million dollars
sorry i know man steve makes us lose all
the time it's a blast dude we still
talking about the renaissance or
we're done the financial reports here's
the thing
sure not bad one thing that came out of
this this happy accident right that i
really love is that
um when we were uh like pre-jk
we were taking into consideration
protecting some people in here right
because some people don't want that
attention some people like our wives and
girlfriends and and friends and people
who were here regularly not everyone is
out here to do comedy solely or whatever
right like they still are being part of
such a hard take on something exactly
and they don't want that kind of
attention and drama like they don't want
to get cancelled or whatever but
everyone here is a dj that just doesn't
give a [ __ ] and what that does is it
creates a freeing environment where we
can just talk freely without thinking
like oh damn you know should we watch
out for like anthony's kings and [ __ ]
because they might like lose all their
money in china yeah you should yeah but
we have what we want we won't we just
ignore it it makes no sense but shout
outs to you though and shout outs to you
and actually all three of you guys
because you guys never really got into
comedy to do comedy but like you know
for the sake of comedy sometimes
you do a crazy hard take and your
heart's not even in it you don't even
believe in what you're just saying it's
just in that moment this was the
funniest thing to do or say or whatever
because we're trying to make each other
laugh yeah we're trying to [ __ ] each
other up right like with with words and
like make it make each other break a
character try not to get fired but i
think like out of context or if people
don't understand the game of comedy
which some there's some like people with
asperger's watching they probably think
we mean every single thing that we
[ __ ] and as a person with asperger's
you could say that i can say that
because they're all just [ __ ] around
like we're just saying [ __ ] to [ __ ]
around like i just [ __ ] called jill's
mom earlier and told her i have a gun to
my head and probably freaked her out for
like 30 seconds or something maybe less
probably less april fool's day you
[ __ ] idiot it's really the first
honestly shout out to you guys for for
for being down to being like always
playing with the fine line of being
canceled and ruining your actual real
businesses that actually like feed you
guys you know for the sake of comedy i
thank you why isn't geo in this room
bart
why isn't you in this room right now she
wants to be a mom
but
surely it's because this room is so
toxic mark gio said that even though
we're toxic men and she hates our guts
um just kidding but but she did tell me
this like you know how she was here
recently
and um you know she was she was like man
i had a great time you know it was great
like reminiscent but she realized that
the energy has changed and she likes
this change but then it also felt like
i'm used to it but i don't want to break
it apart that's how she felt like and i
was like that's yeah that is interesting
because i'm like you're always [ __ ]
welcome you're a part of this family
like let's go right and you fit right in
but she was like no like
when you guys were going at it it felt
like you guys are this all-star
basketball team and you have these plays
and i was like on the sideline and i
didn't want to mess it up we're the
generals dude
he's like poop and kaka
so classic we're grooming him yeah
no but i get i don't i understand well
it's it's interesting too because i
loved
having all the chicks around but i think
people don't realize how much the toxic
group of people just turned them off
from being around
yeah
and
keyboard warriors specifically
i mean even julia talked about this too
when she was a host she's like over the
years it chips away at you and it [ __ ]
with your head so hard right and then
they just want to do a good job she just
wants to host she's not here to do
comedy like we could all take it we have
people saying i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
when i see you one day i don't give a
[ __ ] suck my dick today you know you
guys get those messages dude we had guys
[ __ ] emailing us and saying i'm going
to i'm going to [ __ ] murder you one
day like come on do it
facetime yeah why yes right after all
right cool suck my you know average
sized dick before you kill me please
your dick is huge dude don't worry no no
don't lie
it's all hyped but when you didn't sign
up for this
right like
it i think it's very scary it is like in
the [ __ ] that they do to the girls look
at julia bro she didn't sign up to be a
[ __ ] on-air talent
people
tiff didn't either none of these chicks
did and then they all get [ __ ] with
over the years and then everyone acts
like it's some like [ __ ] war going on
but it's like dude there's so much more
going on than you guys even realize like
because you guys like well not you guys
the the audience the jk real audience is
great
but the dicks are [ __ ] loud and so so
all the girls hear that feel that like
like they all get the [ __ ] from the
group so it sucks but the remaining
careful boys we're okay with all that
let's go it's cause you played safe man
let's play it safe but let's keep going
and for me i just like this new era
where
we can experiment and explore a lot and
it seems like the people that stuck
around to see what would happen they're
along for this ride too and i'm super
grateful for you guys watching too
because
it's almost like we got this new chance
to kind of shed out all of the people
that just didn't mesh well with you know
maybe what we're going to do next yeah
with the next generation sure or where
you saw it going but it's it's really
not even just that for me personally i i
can only speak for myself right but like
i just know that when i'm in this room i
feel like everybody has my back
and i didn't always feel that way like
the whole time it sometimes would feel
like if i said something if i'm on
camera with somebody else they would
maybe try to pone me
like and not in a like fun jovial way
necessarily it was like no they're going
to [ __ ] get me good yeah they're
trying no i don't know what you're
talking about
yeah yeah if i leave
then i think about it for like a couple
days i'm like wait am i like are the am
i just cannon fire for that or like what
the [ __ ] is that
that's my i do feel like
a couple years ago the best at it the
best a couple years ago
when walkism was at its peak right there
were people within guests and people
within our own crew mostly guests for me
yeah that would
sometimes
have these
it would take the comedy out and it
would get into a certain
direction of just like trying to pone
each other yeah and it was no longer
about a group of friends just having a
discussion sometimes we'll argue about
[ __ ] and joke about it and maybe it'll
be heated arguments but we still have
each other's backs but then the people
that are trying to virtue signal and all
that [ __ ] and
i didn't like that man and i'm so glad
that we're past that and we're in a new
era and we're gonna change and i feel
like it reflects in our fan base too our
fan base everybody who was too woke and
all that stuff they're gone yeah and
it's funny too because people are like
well
cool you guys got this anti-walk thing
going on it's like yeah we're for free
health care and
we're real [ __ ] trumpers here you
know
people aren't even listening half the
time it's like uh yeah okay a lot of
people's intro to politics was trump
that's the problem that's the problem so
everybody sees it as either or it's like
come on man there's a whole load of [ __ ]
pre this yeah that's the way you know
you can't [ __ ] teach them that much
history i love the comments or the
thought realm that we're a sausage fest
too because i look around everybody here
and i'm like damn the
the everybody here
has a [ __ ]
uh a woman
back at home
that they like love and respect like
more than themselves or even each other
so we're either simps chads or [ __ ]
oh yeah sorry
talk [ __ ] about don't talk [ __ ] about me
i i i would never respect my woman
anthony
my mom
gio and jill's my hoarder mother is a
[ __ ] also she has cancer so be chill
[Laughter]
[ __ ] get cancer too apparently
speaking of hard times i had two dogs
one of them was female and i kicked that
one in the stomach every day
but to back you up that's a hundred
percent true yeah
in the true definition of being a
feminist
dude
they do
the ones that do
they do paint a picture of word
anti-woman when we're in
loving
long-term relationships with everyone
says speak for yourself
and they can't read between the lines
they think we're all dan bilzerians or
like guys that are like absolutely going
home and yelling at our wives every day
people are so literal that they go based
off just
jokes and just random thoughts are just
ping-ponging off each other versus
actual like we have 10-15 years of video
track record history of how we really
are but no one wants to like see past
yeah did you see the way that anthony
looked at bart while bart was saying
that like no one wants to see past thing
anthony clearly is disagrees with barton
thinks it's all [ __ ] like that's all
that are you looking at my [ __ ] face
through the thumbnail dude of course
jesus
but that's what i'm saying it's all it's
like all this nuancy [ __ ] that we're
all like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about i genuinely want to know i
generally hate women too
selling
i'm telling you my mom is i don't hate
women i just hate seeing them succeed
i hate seeing a boat that's why that's
my biggest thing that's the whole
renaissance we've been trying and this
is the renaissance guys bro man
anti-women
jk2022 i'm almost a good mom not a good
prostitute
[Laughter]
terrible prostitute honestly terrible at
bookkeeping awful yeah that's all i
heard the reviews is that terrible
bookkeeping
that's in the same sentence as
criticizing your prostitution rating
but let us know in the comments below
let us know if you guys are enjoying
this new era how you feel about it if
you don't enjoy it don't let us know
that's the new era
keep it to yourself as i do i do get a
lot of really cool messages from people
that obviously wouldn't have known
anything about me if it wasn't for jk
and they're all super cool so
yeah all you guys that are just writing
to me and just asking me [ __ ] i like it
keep doing her thing if you hate me go
on jill's instagram
[Laughter]
also
also real quick me and joe were talking
about this last night we had dinner
together and it was awesome and it was
like
the best thing about this show is that i
we really don't need to do the show we
don't need it none of us do i [ __ ]
love you boys and i really mean it and
like when i pick up my phone and i have
a bunch of careful boys texts from our
group text
there's nothing better about my day than
hearing from you guys and yeah that's
sweet stupid that's awesome i love you
dude i just mean it like i love it i
love i love um know what you guys are up
to and i love our little vibe that we
have together and for whoever watches it
even when bart's like what's tara
not dead then i get mad
i tell him i tell my wife he's a [ __ ]
idiot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you